okay so we'll talk about this in a
second actually so I think we're good at
three main categories he scales multiple
choice and then free response okay these
are the kinds of questions that you're
gonna ask someone you're gonna pull your
survey but that doesn't answer well okay
how am I actually going to convey these
questions to someone so there are at
least four different ways where you can
sort of break these down into different
categories then you can actually take
these questions that you have carefully
designed and then pose them to other
people so I want to suggest what's a
weight if you want to get data or
someone then you can do it okay so I'm
gonna put actually make this my last one
you can have some kind of online form
all of these yeah like we said you know
the census is going online which is
great okay
you could go for a paper questionnaire
and you can hand it out to people a
paper okay so you could actually talk to
people I'm gonna say that's like a face
to face now the last one is kind of
halfway in between you might see by the
way I've give at least a particular
order I've put them on a scale see what
I did there I wonder if you could work
out what my scale is about what would be
sort of halfway between actually sitting
down with people yeah okay so as you go
down this this list right it's getting
easier and it's getting cheaper right
yeah it's more and more it's more more
practical but of course there's a
trade-off right so the thing that I'm
gonna put in between here is what
happens there about six or six-thirty in
your house because that's the time when
most people are harmed and the phone
rings right and it's someone from
Melbourne actually trying to like get a
solicitor
a photo surveillance a very - is easy on
a cheaper than a face-to-face interview
but not quite as much as just saying can
you fill this therefore yep yeah okay so
like a nativity though we should say
obviously depending on the way you
designed the it's a great way and
depending on the weight you design it
like you could do a face to face
interview someone and say hey this would
be completely confidential all of your
data will be aggregated taken away from
your name etc okay now last thing I want
to talk about is um biases so you design
your collector questions you think about
the way you're going to pose them to
people but you have to be really careful
about trying to make sure your survey is
as objective as possible and it's going
to get the most truthful answers right
so there are two sort of bias is kind of
like something that tells you towards r3
in one way versus another regardless of
whether it is true or not that's what we
mean by a bias okay so I actually have
I'm gonna get you guys to go and look
this up later cuz super interesting
there are two broad categories of biases
the first one is a response bias and
I'll give you a couple of examples so
this excuse me I feel feeling out of
survey right I'm filling out a survey
there's a bias called social
desirability bias yeah I wonder if you
could guess just from the name what you
think is bias means you're filling out a
survey and the question asks you
something like you know do you
do you exercise regularly right now if
you're so lot about my age it's highly
socially desirable to say yeah sure
totally exercise really regularly just
so I'm good here I'm gonna give an
answer that I think is socially
desirable but even if it's not truthful
I'm like well this is kind of what I'd
like to be and so that's that's kind of
the way I'm going to lean more towards
that way rather than accuracy so social
desirability so you've got to be really
careful when you ask questions and now
the response bias is what's called an
quiescence described here kind of it's
sort of I'm always gonna agree yeah
who's gonna agree with someone now if
you freeze all of your questions in a
particular way we tend to want to
acquiesce with the way oppression is
right so I'll give you an example a
personality survey all right it could
ask two questions you know do you like
to spend time alone versus do you like
to spend time with you know groups of
people okay now if I see both of those
questions as I look at each individual
question I'm kinda tipping towards well
I could agree with both of those because
I do like to spend time alone
nobody can we spend any time for people
quite introverted so like I'm just gonna
sort of tend toward saying yes to
whatever way the question is phrased
right how did you get away from this how
do you try to avoid this bias that
everyone has
okay so I couldn't avoid having like the
two questions that are going to cook it
at each other that's one way of doing
another way I could do it is it all of
the questions that are phrasing I want
to make sure an equal number of them
have a case a positive and each of an
equal and I have a number of babies like
you should answer in the negative for
some of these questions if you're
reading it properly okay so I got a
couple of response biases there there
are more but this just sort of gives you
a bit of a taste note and the second
category is just specific to surveys but
it has a real effect on something you
should actually just go look up like
even if the most detail you look at is
the Wikipedia article for a list of
cognitive biases it's super interesting
I don't know how many of your interest
in psychology at all but there are lots
of different kinds of just the way we
think is always biased in one direction
and the way that you answer questions
therefore is flavored butter so I'll
give you some examples
Oh stereotyping we all stereotype on you
kind of don't have a choice
right because you don't know everything
and so you have to base your knowledge
on a broad range of things based on you
know what do you think of all my dad
always loves to start sentences like
I've got racist but and then he'll say
to me something which is completely
generalized for like the one person of a
certain ethnicity than he's ever met in
his whole lifetime
so we stereotype and if you are get
asked questions about your types of
people or types of experiences that will
clearly be favored by flavor by the very
very smaller instances you have that's
what stereotypes are and the last one is
our really fancy day it's cold it's
called reactive devaluation yeah that's
a really really fancy out of this I
causes a lot of coming up with fancy
names for things
I want you come back to this list we
broke earlier about how to ask questions
right now we already pointed out it's
clearly more expensive to do face to
face interviews over just giving people
on my phone sending them a link it's a
please answer us right but one of the
challenges that's presented by a
face-to-face is you what its
disadvantages is that depending on who
is asking you the questions you
sometimes react by sort of saying oh
it's only because of you or the person
who passed me okay so just think about
if you ever had like a telemarketer ask
you know different things
and you kind of your automatic reaction
is I don't really want to talk to you I
don't really want to you know agree with
what you're saying when I talk to
salespeople I automatically have this
you're just trying to sell me there was
like that's like I already on before
I've even spoken to this person
I'm like you're trying to sell me
something so my reaction is to devalue
the kinds of things you're going to say
to me so this is kind of loaded like if
they're asking you an opinion about do
you value this or that then who's asking
you that question has a huge impact it
includes you to answer one way versus
another so you have to be very careful
that how you design questions and how
you actually convey those questions to
other people okay